hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
checking out the trailer the official
second trailer for ant-man
here we go everyone shut up everyone
just shut up we're gonna watch his
[ __ ] trailer 20 years ago I cleaned
the seat but it was dangerous so I hid
it from the world my assist Darren cross
then we can obsess with me creating my
formula if this technology gets out it's
going to be chaos Scott this is your
chance to become a hero I need you to be
the head man I think our first move
should be calling the Avengers this is a
shoot acknowledged like the Iron Man
suit way too
when you're small superhuman strength
he likes my bullet my best shot
so you need to know how to punch oh sure
we had a bunch show me out it that's how
you punch
[Music]
you're just a face
Oh
a man man I know wasn't my idea Wow
there's no reason to be scared oh no no
then don't get scared
good how'd you do that bro don't freak
out look at your shoulder all right so
the trailers that show us much that's
new but it was worth it just for that
one [ __ ] lie I think our first thing
should be to call the Avengers Oh
self-aware humor is the best and I like
these trailers because the one ant-man
was first introduced to us from the film
it was like so serious now we have all
these trailers that are really promoting
the fun of it me yeah you can't really
talk about much new things because the
trailer was essentially similar just
with different music but more I see this
the more excited I get it looks like
it's gonna be a great addition to the
Marvel Canon Paul Rudd looks like he's
gonna rock it there's always a new line
that they show him do that I'm always
like yeah Paul Rudd he's [ __ ] awesome
and he's gonna prove it and he's gonna
become a [ __ ] superstar now anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the channel
if you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
where if we get enough followers we can
get even more product placement most
dangerous town it's a good documentary
look who Wiltshire hey right it's me
Luke from Luke Games ask for a shout-out
but I forgot my manners and forgot to
say thanks anyway I like to resend it
can I have a shout-out you and the gang
have been a big inspiration to me and
you're one of the reasons why I drew
reactions on my channel oh great another
reactor that's that's awesome we don't
get enough of those for it I've gained
massive secession show me what I want to
do in the future in collage first off
you're going to get into college you
gotta learn to spell better it's not
collage it's there's an e not an A again
thanks so much it will be an honor to
you spelled it owner like boner but it's
it's an O no need to give me a shout-out
thanks again and thanks to the future I
have now I love you guys and I hope you
reach a million subscribers at the end
of this year that will be awesome thanks
for your time bye everyone check out
Luke games he's a little illiterate
other than that he's got a good gaming
channel those reactions
how many people are gonna start doing
reactions when I first started it was
like Gator Martin now there's like 15
other [ __ ] people
maybe even more there's actually a lot
more so welcome to the territory Luke